Oh
motown morrissey c'est une ville fantôme le
meurtre kappa le d
tout le monde a un nom pour l'appeler pour moi
c'est juste Detroit l'endroit où je suis
né l'endroit où je vis Qui suis-je
mon nom est je serais une mangue Henderson  Manor
tout en cire ils m'appellent mr.  jour
en anglais, un ghetto est un
groupe de personnes qui sont les mêmes qui
vivent au même endroit après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, le
ghetto a signifié un groupe de
pauvres vivant ensemble à
proximité et dans cette mesure encore
plus, cela ne fait même pas  ça veut dire un tas de
gens plus ça veut dire un tas de
Noirs vivant ensemble et de mauvaises
conditions sans espoir pour l'avenir
et aucune idée de comment y arriver c'est à
quoi ressemble le ghetto
une [ __ ] de bombe frappant tout
c'était des familles qui semblaient parties parties  disparu
disparu disparu disparu maintenant dis-moi
où d'autre peux-tu voir ça maintenant quand je
dis que je vis dans le ghetto je vis parmi
ces gens mon peuple mais je ne pense pas
beaucoup comme la plupart d'entre eux et je n'ai pas
le  mentalité de ghetto et nous pourrions et
j'ai eu plus d'opportunités que beaucoup
et c'est là que le truc de la classe entre
en jeu Je n'ai aucune idée d'affamer mes
parents en rentrant ivre à la maison Je ne sais rien
de ces choses parce que je
ne savais pas  les expérimenter et c'est un
phénomène courant dans le ghetto quand j'étais
enfant je voulais un de ces
bâtiments je fantasmais d'avoir un
de ces bâtiments et d'avoir un studio
ou peut-être souvent l'un d'eux j'étais un
enfant que vous
utilisiez  travailler ici les gens avaient tout c'est des
emplois non rien à vendre à louer
tout c'était le plan du premier étage oh
qui est sorti le premier qui a
fait faillite et ici même 200 000
personnes travaillaient ici et maintenant elles
n'ont pas  un enfant et c'est le
début de nouveau j'ai grandi avec ma famille
très proche donc c'était un peu comme
grandir avec une couverture sur vous tout le
temps où nous étions sur nous n'étions pas riches mais
sur la famille très travailleuse de ma famille
donc nous  nous avons survécu et vécu et il y avait
beaucoup d'amour dans la maison et cela m'a en quelque sorte
permis de poursuivre mes rêves
là où son couplet commence à demander hey
juste là oh alors ce que nous devons faire
maintenant, c'est faire la structure de la chanson
Oh
d'accord maintenant ça  le magazine vient de oh
c'était dans ton courrier Jill d'accord mais il
dit quelque chose ici en japonais
expliquant quelque chose parce qu'il était vide et
une fois j'ai pensé qu'il avait été mangé mais vous pouvez
voir qu'il parlait de certaines personnes
malades que j'ai eu dans le secteur de la musique à  un
très jeune âge, nous n'en sommes pas plus l'affaire,
donc juste de la musique parce que c'était
toujours de la musique à la maison ma euh ma
grand-mère jouait toujours du piano
ma mère mon oncle chantait mon
père quand j'étais chez mon père
il le ferait  jouer de la musique soul et de la musique jazz
et en arrière-plan, donc dès que je me
souviens, j'ai aimé ça et à la minute où
je pouvais me lever sur le tabouret de piano, je
jouais de la musique, donc chaque année, il ajoutait
quelque chose que vous savez depuis qu'il était
petit, il  dirait d'accord maman j'ai besoin d'une
boîte à rythmes j'ai besoin de tout et la
première fois qu'il est allé au studio aurait
dû embaucher quelqu'un pour faire le mixage
et quel est cet homme de l'ingénieur il a dit
maman il a dit j'ai regardé cet homme
qu'il n'est pas  faire autant et je ne
vais pas lui peindre tout cet argent pour venir
là-bas et il a dit que tout ce dont j'avais besoin, c'est
tout ce dont j'avais besoin, c'est d'un livre, alors il a appelé
et a découvert où se trouvait le livre sur cette
machine que l'homme avait était  en utilisant l'
ingénieur utilisait et la prochaine fois qu'ils
avaient besoin d'ingénieur, il était d'
ingénieur je veux dire que je n'ai jamais vraiment dit cette
partie les ingénieurs avaient l'habitude de parler
au-dessus de ma tête parce que j'étais noir vous
savez qu'ils penseraient que je ne pouvais pas discuter
alors  ils me diraient n'importe quoi s'il s'agissait d'
un client payant, ils ne leur auraient pas
dit comment faire de l'ingénierie pour qu'ils
parlent par-dessus ma tête
j'avais en fait une aptitude à ça alors je l'ai
appris j'ai appris à faire de l'ingénierie à
un très jeune âge  et au moment où j'avais
16 ans, notre ingénieur du son et je suis un
jeune producteur de disques prometteur, donc je
suis content d'être toujours content qu'il puisse faire de la
musique que je ne comprends toujours pas et je
ne vois pas comment quelqu'un  commence à faire de la
musique à la maison, puis parcourt
le monde avec, c'est toujours un mystère pour
moi.
tomberait d'un toit et se
casserait le cou, tu sais, alors maintenant il l'a fait
dans sa musique
grand-père appelle ses propres coups, donc je savais que
c'était que je savais que c'était une option
avoir sa propre entreprise c'est définitivement
une option Je ne pense pas que je n'ai jamais regardé
ça comme si je pouvais être comme grand-père et avoir
ma propre entreprise Je savais juste que je  Je
n'avais pas à travailler si je ne voulais pas,
mais en même temps, mon grand-père m'a
toujours inculqué que j'avais toujours
une maison, donc même si j'échouais, j'avais
un endroit où aller, donc je n'avais jamais peur
d'échouer.  m'a permis de suivre mes
rêves
sinon là-bas pas trop mal aujourd'hui pas
de pluie dans les prévisions pour la première fois
dans quelques jours un ciel ensoleillé tout au long de l'
après-midi et des températures qui devraient
atteindre le milieu des années 70
j'ai vécu un divorce avec la
mère de Sydney et  pendant ce temps, je
n'étais pas sûr de savoir si j'allais
partir, tu sais totalement quitter sa
mère, alors j'ai fait et puis j'ai fait cette
musique,
c'est un peu doux et un peu déprimant
au début, puis ça progresse
au milieu et puis  c'est toute cette
voix aiguë qui m'a en quelque sorte
rappelé des cris mais en gros
la chanson de Sydney et je l'ai appelée la chanson
de Sydney et je m'excuse de me voir
avant le premier crochet c'est quelque chose que
j'entendrais et maintenant je vous l'ai dit
que tu écoutais pour avoir quitté
sa mère, donc à bien des égards, la
chanson de Sydney était une sortie, c'est ce que j'avais l'habitude
de pouvoir quitter ce
mariage
Oh Oh
Oh
devrais-tu le faire aujourd'hui et
juste étudier oh  d'accord d'accord étudiez
ce que nous allons faire ce que je suppose allez ici
eh bien je suppose que vous travaillez peut-être sur les
paroles du Seigneur signez la boîte vide d'accord eh
bien combien avez-vous étudié ce que
vous voulez dire ne fonctionnera tout simplement pas non je devais dire
tout cela, Sydney m'a fait
tout changer dans ma vie, j'ai dû changer ma
vie à l'envers et maintenant je suis tellement habitué à
elle ou à son système, vous savez que je
ne pouvais pas imaginer une autre façon de vivre
Sparrow plus haut huit ig8 H es  Je suis eei le
plus lent lent EST le plus heureux h egg PP
J'utilise plus haut dans un sens je suis plus haut
que toi tu ferais mieux d'utiliser plus haut dans un
sens les spectacles que tu connais le
sens du monde
tu n'utilises que des décisions plus élevées pour t'avoir
un exemple d'accord notre appartement est plus haut
que les gens qui marchent dans la rue
maintenant vous utilisez plus haut dans une phrase qui
montre que vous savez ce que cela signifie plus haut
le ciel est plus haut que les appartements oh
c'était un peu du plagiat sur ce que
je faisais mais je  Je vais comprendre qu'il y a
tellement de choses qui lui arrivent même à sept huit
ans, il y a tellement de choses qui lui arrivent
alors elle essaie de tout traiter et d'
agir en conséquence et la façon dont vous agissez
en conséquence est d'agir comme les autres
enfants maintenant le problème avec  c'est
que les autres enfants pourraient ne pas
agir de la façon dont cela va
réussir pour eux à l'avenir et
ces choses c'est ce que j'essaie d'enseigner à
Sydney et vous savez que j'essaie de
lui inculquer l'amour de la lecture euh l'amour de
des connaissances pour apprendre pourquoi certaines choses
sont comme elles sont afin qu'elle puisse
les comprendre autrement que juste vous savez
mémoriser un fait et le purger donc
ceux si vous savez ce sont les choses que j'essaie
vraiment de lui enseigner plus que
tout et la compassion vous savez  les gens
ne s'en soucient plus les uns les autres oui
amour hé
e
Oh
toi
ici à Detroit est l'ave est l'un des
endroits les plus racistes des États-Unis
je pense parce que les gens sont pour la plupart
plus séparés la ville de livonia
qui est  l'une des villes les plus blanches
des États-Unis et Detroit étant l'une
des séries les plus noires, je pense que c'est
comme le deuxième et le troisième plus grand noir
vu aux États-Unis, ils sont juste
à côté l'un de l'autre, donc le problème avec
ça à tout moment vous avez  un peuple qui
ne connaît pas les autres personnes vous n'avez
eu aucun contact avec des noirs sauf
pour les regarder à la télévision ou si
vous n'avez aucun contact avec des blancs ou
des mexicains ou qui que ce soit d'autre que
la télévision alors cela engendre le racisme et
c'est donc ce que nous avons  ici et ce n'est pas du
racisme manifeste comme vous l'avez vu dans les années 60,
c'est plus une attitude je sens que je sais
de quoi vous parlez je sais que vous ne
m'aimez pas parce que je vous connais parce que je
connais tous les hommes blancs à la télévision
hé quel est son nom
stand
submerge une entreprise en pleine croissance Je l'ai vue
grandir du sous-sol de notre
maison familiale jusqu'à l'endroit où il se trouve maintenant et
tout cela à cause de Mike et de plusieurs
autres, vous savez qu'ils croyaient en la
musique avant tout, mais ils se
dirigeraient eux-mêmes  et ils ont vraiment
travaillé dur pour faire des choses ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui, alors la fusion est un bon exemple de la façon
dont les gens sont de nationalités différentes,
d'horizons différents, d'âges différents, de
philosophies différentes, de
religions différentes peuvent se réunir et faire
quelque chose de positif ouais définitivement je
pense que cela vous parle  quel que soit le
groupe de personnes mis de côté, c'est une
discrimination et non une chose personnelle
qu'ils mettent de côté, je crois qu'ils pourraient
faire tout ce qu'ils désirent tous faire, hein,
écoutez, je comprends cela, mais nous voulions
imprimer avec cette dame, alors vous savez que
ce serait le cas  être quelque chose que vous
savez mais nous ne pouvons pas y remédier sans
frais supplémentaires pour nous vous voyez ce que je
dis d'accord c'est cool je peux je peux
vivre sans je peux vivre sans buisson je
peux vivre avec notre réponse Bible mais tu
sais que tu ne  je me fiche du ministre
louis farrakhan je pense qu'il est drôle d'accord eh
bien nous avons perdu nous avons perdu blush nous avons perdu un pour
courir principalement parce que les buissons actuels avec cela
je devrais répondre de mes mains le
président ne peut être sur aucune œuvre d'art mais
il n'y a pas de président  Je dis l'homme que
vous auriez pu mettre comme George
Washington parce que sa marque de fabrique oui donc
il nous faut un générique sur tableau noir
submergé a été
créé en 91 par michael banks et
Krista Robinson donc Mike a eu l'idée de
réunir toutes les activités pressantes de
Detroit et une unité il  appelé ça
submergé parce que c'est de la musique underground
et alors ils ont commencé à gérer le paiement
de l'usine de pressage en expédiant les disques
aux distributeurs et cela impliquait à partir de
là que je me suis impliqué moi et
michael avons toujours été amis depuis
le début des années 90 et donc nous sommes restés en contact
et c'était une situation où nous pouvions nous
réunir pour des affaires et
c'est à ce moment-là que je me suis impliqué dans
la réorganisation submergée, vous savez, j'y ai mis ma
touche, alors
nous avons restauré ce bâtiment à partir de ce que vous
pourriez considérer comme un état délabré, c'était
une route difficile, vous savez juste tout le monde
est juste vraiment content du travail que nous
avons fait et ils ont été surpris de voir que
certains chats comme nous étaient capables de faire
quelque chose comme ça en fait,
ils ont fait des blagues sur nous et ce qu'ils
ne font pas, ils nous appellent ensemble comme un  groupe
aux ingénieurs du ghetto ouais façon d'avoir nos
ingénieurs il est honnête je n'écoutais pas j'ai
eu le spectacle si
bon
ça a l'air bien je ne pensais pas que tu te
souviens que tu es comme je veux entendre ce que
le disque avec le poêle armani
ne bombarde pas l'esprit ici submergé est
vraiment bien c'est fondamentalement nous sommes tous de la
famille même si nous venons tous d'où nous
pouvons  ce ne sont pas tous des gars réunis entre
Mike et Krista et euh tout le monde que
vous connaissez de la région de Detroit
mais nous sommes tous comme une famille qui travaille pour vous
tout le monde travaille ici pour l'
amour de travailler ici vous savez ce que je veux dire
et la sphère c'est  tout va bien, nous nous
entraidons tous et c'est un bon
endroit pour travailler mec c'est un bon environnement
communauté vous savez voir l'ancien jour
à l'ancien d'accord oui nous étions les
uns sur les autres alors ils écoutaient
le mixage  juste sous ce
ministère demain qu'est-ce que tu
vois ou tu sais ici avec le
bas je ne t'entends pas je pensais que c'était
le bombardier furtif Octonauts
vous êtes comme la musique d'accord eh bien il y
a eu beaucoup de musique musique populaire qui
vient de Detroit  au fil des ans, je
parie que vous connaissez tous Motown,
certains d'entre vous s'en sortent bien, c'était avant
votre naissance, mais c'est un autre type
de musique qui a vu le jour à Detroit et
qui a vu le jour au cours des 20 à 25 dernières
années. Motown Records  était le
plus grand succès de son temps et
je ne sais pas peut-être la maison de disques la plus réussie de tous les temps,
ils ont battu le numéro un après le numéro
un, je veux dire qu'ils devaient signifier la
plus grande chose jamais vue pour la musique soul par
Motown étant  fondé et Detroit par
les Detroiters et les catalyseurs étant à
Detroit avec le talent de Detroit que le
système de celui-ci serait resté, mais le
fait que ce sont les décisions commerciales et
les choses qui se sont produites qui ont
déraciné notre industrie d'ici et
c'est parti c'est parti quand  huit quand
ils l'ont quitté, il est parti avec eux quand l'
industrie change, vous dites techno d'accord,
combien d'entre vous connaissent
le son techno à droite,
le musée historique de Detroit était une
idée plus large pour l'exposition historique de l'exposition techno de Detroit
et donc c'est bon pour
les écoliers le  voyez que ce sont tous
ces gars en décembre qui sont allés dans les mêmes
écoles où ils sont allés ont grandi dans les mêmes
rues qui parcourent le monde et
qui font toutes ces
choses merveilleuses et font cette musique à partir de
rien et ont toutes ces affaires et ce
rembourrage  Je pense que c'est excitant pour
un enfant de voir, vous savez, si je n'avais pas été
un enfant, ils ont vu l'exposition techno que j'aurais
pu comprendre de manière très
différente si vous regardez la scène
ici, vous pouvez voir combien  des gens
du monde entier viennent
profiter du festival techno qui se tient
chaque année à hart plaza et comme je l'ai dit,
il se tiendra ce week-end, vous
avez beaucoup d'artistes différents,
beaucoup d'occasions différentes d'entendre
les créateurs de la techno  le son je peux me
plonger dans la motown dans le sens où un
gars sur le boulevard peut marcher dans la
rue apporter notre sonnette et
avoir une opportunité vous savez et avoir une chance de
faire n'importe quoi pour
avoir son contrat d'enregistrement obtenir son signe d'étiquette
pour obtenir une distribution ou signer un livre et
un accord et circuler partout dans le
monde du DJ, vous savez que ces
services professionnels
lui sont plus disponibles qu'ils ne devaient l'être parce que
vous savez quand j'ai commencé,
c'était nulle part où je pouvais  allez, je suis très fier
de faire partie de quelque chose qui offre
tant d'opportunités aux gens que vous connaissez
certainement
Brandon Calloway à la maison, il a en fait fait
la meilleure bande démo que j'aie jamais entendue
et immédiatement j'ai dit que je voulais
les signer je  je dois les rencontrer et euh il est venu
au studio et il avait 18 ans 18
et 19 quelque chose comme ça euh vert je suis lui euh
il n'avait été nulle part il n'a rien
fait tu ne sais rien il venait de
sortir de  lycée et tout ce qu'il était
comme raccrocher au studio alors euh
et beaucoup d'une certaine manière j'ai adopté Brandon tu
sais c'est comme mon petit frère un autre
petit frère et donc il était avec
moi depuis que nous descendons du
jour  un puits nous avons surtout Brian qui la
boit mal oh je marche avec tu
sais donne moi du lait et des biscuits avec du
lait et des biscuits hahaha
heureusement du lait et des biscuits je ne pouvais pas
croire que des frites ah là et du lait cette
vraie merde et ensuite rien sur
trouble man va te faire [ __ ] oh cool bag boho fais
la traite cool tu sais qu'il est vraiment
proche de moi tu sais qu'il aime que
j'ai des frères de feu mais il aime un autre
grand frère que moi tu sais qu'il
m'a beaucoup montré sur la vie et la musique alors
bon après-midi  vous écoutez 90,9
FM w DTR Detroit juste un
avertissement d'orage d'annonce rapide émis
pour le comté de Macomb et qui est émis
jusqu'en 753 c'est 90,9 FM w DTR detroit
tout nouveau morceau de ces
gens merveilleux là-bas à submerger le morceau
s'appelle fais-le  faites-le équipe sunspot
non faites-le simplement pour nous débarrasser de vous savez allons-y
parlons-en bien allons-y
vous
la plupart des musiciens je sais qu'ils ont un
bon gagne-pain ils aiment ce qu'ils font
ils font le  le genre de musique qu'ils aiment
faire ils n'ont pas de grande maison de disques
pour leur dire le genre de musique
à faire ou leur dire où aller ou
jouer un concert qu'ils n'aiment pas jouer
ils le font exactement ce qu'ils veulent  pour
ce faire, ils vivent dans leurs rêves à travers une
avenue que moi et mes partenaires ont faite
donc j'en suis content ouais mais la plupart des
musiciens doivent trouver un travail un vrai travail
et faire de la musique comme passe-temps ackerman quand j'étais
petit était le  Dans les années 80, c'était vraiment sauvage
ici loin de ses trucs de dopage alors j'ai
levé les yeux j'ai vu beaucoup j'ai vu beaucoup d'
argent sur la scène beaucoup de gens se font
tirer dessus et merde mais je ne voulais pas
suivre cette route j'ai toujours eu un  j'aime la
musique depuis que je suis petit donc je suis toujours
resté fidèle à ça quand je me suis tourné vers ça quand je
suis devenu adolescent j'ai eu des platines
puis à partir de là j'ai commencé à produire et
je reste avec la musique c'est ce que j'aime
faire mais certaines personnes aimeraient peut-être  jouer
au basket tout le monde pas dans la merde sauvage
mais vous avez quelque chose qui est
dans la merde sauvage et ils
font n'importe quoi ici Je ne leur en veux pas
parce que j'ai juste l'air de l'avoir dit
avant c'est comme ça qu'ils écrivent c'est ce qu'ils ont
vu et  tu sais que je dis parfois
et je ne sais même pas que c'est ton
propre choix à ce moment-là parce que si tu as même
vu ça tout le temps et c'est tout ce que
tu sais c'est ce que tu vas faire si
tu es autour de ça tout le temps  avoir aller
à l'école ta mère à la maison ivre fumer du
crack ou quoi que ce soit tu vas le vendre
ou faire la même chose donc mais il y a beaucoup
de gens qui font beaucoup de choses positives
ici aussi tu sais tout parce que je
reste en dehors de ça je  fais mon truc tu sais
et j'aime juste t'en tenir à la musique mec la
vie c'est quand tu regardes les dernières nouvelles
et sur les dernières nouvelles tu entends des
nouvelles déchirantes et chaque jour les
dernières nouvelles ne changent pas grand homme fait
petit homme vérifiant ce changement vérifiant
ceci  changer alors peut-être en vérifiant cette
marque, ils disent que les rues sont dures maintenant
le sol et se tiennent mais qui est le blâme
pour plus et je bascule une grosse bombe a explosé
et six soldats ont été abattus cette guerre est
insensée et elle doit être arrêtée encore
nous xer par deux  des flics se sont fait tirer dessus ou
pourquoi l'a-t-il fait, c'est qu'il a
influencé mentalement de jeunes chiots noirs et blancs
qui sortent du liquide et aux nouvelles un
grand bar de maison quand ils ont creusé dans
les cendres cinq enfants ont été trouvés la cause
d'un radiateur parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait '  t avoir
des prix du gaz de chauffage exorbitants, c'est pour moi
et que mon travail, je ne peux même pas avoir un jour
de congé, mais cette dame des nouvelles parle de
licenciements dans toute la ville, l'endroit est dans les
séries éliminatoires, restez fidèle aux vrais trucs petite
fille frappée par un gros  Le camion Marshall Fields
c'est la vie
imaginez être d'un monde
bien déposé
était un mode de vie à
vous de voir
merci de
saisir l'occasion si
sans cela comme wow et
ils louent
amen bien
oh rien n'est vrai que vous êtes un mur
doit y renoncer  pour que tu ne
gazes pas la plage
ton cœur
j'avais 16 ans et j'allais à 17 ans et c'était une
expérience que je porterai avec moi pour le
reste de ma vie parce que euh juste voir
les choses que j'ai vues était euh
traumatisant de dire le  moins parce que
vous savez que vous vous attendriez à ce genre
de chose en n'allant que dans les films,
mais j'ai en fait vécu à travers les chars
qui montent et descendent la rue, la
Garde nationale tire en fait sur des
gens qui meurent dans les rues de gens qui
brûlent et prennent des pilules
un ami de la pilule juste en train d'aller et juste la ville
c'était le pandémonium et les épidémies qui
ont suivi qui n'ont pas eu l'exposition nationale ou
internationale comme l'émeute l'a fait
mais en fait étaient sinon plus graves aussi
graves que l'émeute l'était je ne pense pas que
le  l'émeute qui s'est produite en 67 pourrait se
reproduire personnellement parce que je pense que je
pense vraiment que les Noirs, même les
Noirs pauvres, se sentent généralement
habilités dans l'inter entendu qu'ils ont dans
le capot, ils pensent que que ce soit par
des affaires illégales ou par
une bourse ou acheter quelque chose  en
volant par une sorte de moyen, ils
vont surmonter d'une manière ou d'une autre
individuellement ils ne le regardent pas Je
ne pense pas que ce soit autant un
esprit communautaire qu'à l'époque et
vous devez certainement avoir un
l'esprit communautaire pour monter à l'émeute, donc je ne pense pas que
cela se reproduise parce que je pense que
les gens ont trop d'
attitude individuelle, vous savez, ce serait plus un
individu qui s'énerve et fait
quelque chose de fou qu'un groupe de personnes
ou le  toute la communauté parce que je ne
pense pas que nous nous identifions plus comme une
communauté dans nos cœurs
regardez-vous fille
je n'irai pas devant vous tous vous avez un
truc que je vais vous frapper moi l'histoire
est une blague je  signifie que lorsque vous commencez à
parler d'événements, les événements noirs sont l'
histoire des Noirs, il n'y a rien de tel, vous
savez, c'est comme si c'était comme un Sasquatch ou
quelque chose qui ne se produit tout simplement pas, donc non,
nous n'avons pas appris les émeutes de
l'histoire, j'en apprends plus sur les émeutes
en écoutant mes parents, mes grands-parents
en parler, j'ai appris dans les
livres d'histoire que l'éducation n'est pas encore
importante mais plus importante que
l'éducation est de comprendre et d'apprendre
à apprendre, les gens prennent
tout ce que cette chronique
leur lance à la télévision dans les médias et ils
ne  Je ne veux pas l'apprendre, donc je pense que la
maison doit être améliorée pour que les choses
s'améliorent, les gens doivent accorder plus d'
attention à leurs enfants, le
membre
Detroit pour moi est une ville que vous savez, je
ne pense pas que ce soit un début ou en elle
Je sais que ça a commencé quelque part peut-être que ça le
fera à un endroit mais c'est en cours c'est
un changement et ça dit une sorte d'
évolution constante vous savez vers une chose ou
une autre oh je vois les choses comme étant plus
ouvertes qu'à
l'époque où  Je disais peut-être que 657 il y aura du
lent et graduel pour que la graine
revienne Je crois que ça reviendra
Je ne pense pas que ça va
revenir de la même façon qu'avant Je pense que
ce qui m'intéresse le plus alors  l'
extérieur de Detroit en regardant à quoi il
ressemblait serait l'attitude des gens
à changer, vous savez si cela peut arriver,
alors vous pouvez toujours peindre une
maison, mais si l'intérieur est brûlé, à quel point
est-il bon
Oh,
très certainement, je pourrais vivre à l'extérieur  de
Detroit mais je ne pouvais pas donner deux pères
Detroit parce que je ne pouvais pas entendre trop loin
de ma famille
il y a beaucoup de talent ici donc ça pourrait être
mauvais pour les affaires pour moi de déménager
ailleurs donc vous savez que c'est beaucoup de
facteurs à  Garde-moi à Detroit, tu sais que
cette ville est l'endroit où se trouve mon cœur
et où appartient mon âme, je ne
le changerais pour rien au monde